jean marc sylvestre bonjour bonjour
libye heureux de vous retrouver sur le
plateau de la matinale verte et france
alors en octobre le prix du gaz avaient
flambé pour cause de reprise économique
puis il était retombé à un niveau plus
modeste et depuis lundi les prix sont
remontés sur fond de risque de guerre en
ukraine et d'incertitude autour de north
stream ii alors il faut nous nous
décrypter tout ça oui alors les
fluctuations du gaz une fête du prix du
gaz sont un peu compliquée à décrypter
elles dépendent vous l'avez dit de
plusieurs facteurs le premier de ces
facteurs s'est évidemment l'équilibré
entre l'offre et la demande des raisons
économiques sur le plan mondial de
l'énergie en général ça bouge en
fonction des activités pourquoi parce
que toutes les énergies sont
complémentaires alors l'offre de gaz et
est assez connu un le principal
fournisseur mondial
c'est la russie il approvisionne près de
la moitié de l'europe et face à cette
offre eh bien il ya une demande et la
demande des pans de l'activité
économique alors vous le rappeliez en
octobre quand la croissance mondiale
s'est activée partout dans le monde à la
sortie des confinement il ya eu un
afflux d'achats non seulement de gaz
d'ailleurs mais aussi de pétrole de
charbon et d'électricité
c'est à ce moment là que on s'est
inquiété de la hausse des prix et c'est
à ce moment là que la france pour éviter
ou pour calmer la grogne sociale qui
montait et bien a annoncé qu'on allait
distribuer des chèques énergie d'échec
inflation ce sont ces chèques là qui
sont d'ailleurs envoyé par la poste
depuis lundi à plus de 30 millions de
français environ qui vont recevoir un
chèque de 100 à 250 euros selon les les
catégories sociales pour amortir les
factures d'essence et de chauffage et on
a vu en novembre d'ailleurs ça c'est un
paradoxe avant même que les chèques
soient envoyés que la flambée des prix
s'est un peu calmée parce que l'offre et
la demande se sont équilibrés alors ça
c'est l'explication économique mais il
ya une deuxième série de facteurs 1 qui
pèse sur ses prix ce sont les forces
géopolitiques la de la demande est une
explication mais il faut savoir aussi
que le gaz russe est livré au client par
des gazoducs vous avez un gazoduc au
nord qui traverse la mer baltique et qui
arrive en allemagne c'est le north
stream 1 et un projet de gars stream 2
pour doubler un peu cette capacité ces
gigantesques comme projet c'est un enjeu
pour l'europe pour la russie vous avez
aussi un gazoduc qui traversent
l'ukraine alors il se trouve que
l'exploitation des gazoducs du nord sont
très controversés par l'allemagne parce
que curieusement l'allemagne est plutôt
tournée vers les gaz qu'elle fait venir
des états unis qui se passe qui sont des
gaz cher c'est les gaz de schiste et qui
pour les écologistes devraient pourtant
être rebutant puisqu'ils y sont
carbonées beaucoup plus que les gars
sort le nouveau ministre des affaires
étrangères celui qui est dans la
nouvelle coalition a dit cette semaine
que le gazoduc north stream 2 ne pouvait
pas être approuvé tant qu'il y aurait
des tensions à la frontière ukrainienne
dont il mêle des facteurs politiques
dans ce raisonnement pourquoi bien parce
que la russie et l'ukraine se regardent
en chiens de faïence on sait on dit
qu'on aura on lit en europe que le
kremlin aurait rassemblé cent mille
soldats à la frontière donc pour faire
simple les marchés internationaux
considèrent qu'il ya des risques sur
l'approvisionnement en gaz donc les prix
remonte brutalement et depuis lundi
entre 10 et 15% hier soir on était à 116
euros 75 l'équivalent mégawattheure au
niveau du record atteint en octobre
c'est à dire au niveau qui avait
déclenché les fameux chèque alors tout
ça signifie que le kremlin qui a la main
sur les gazoducs pourrait évidemment
utiliser le gaz comme arme politique
dans les affaires qui oppose la russie
et l'europe c'est du moins le procès
qu'on est en train de lui faire mais
alors est ce que véritablement le gaz
peut être utilisé comme une arme
politique alors bien sûr d'admir poutine
a les moyens de faire varier les prix du
gaz puisque il peut fermer les robinets
il peut fermer le robinet afin d'obliger
les européens à construire par exemple
le fameux north stream 2 et puis
d'arrêter des menaces de sanctions
lancée par les états unis notamment
relayé par l'europe de développer et
c'est une arme à double tranchant un
parce que le gaz rapporte à la russie
énormément d'argent la russie a besoin
de cet argent là est par ailleurs
gazprom qui est la grande société de
commercialisation à toujours respecter
les contrats signés donc d'un côté vous
avez la politique et de l'autre vous
avez le business est au milieu vous avez
des marchés qui cherchent un peu leur
équilibre alors oui jean marc c'est est
ce que cette forme et va durer et est ce
que ça peut avoir des conséquences sur
l'activité alors c'est évidemment la
question que tout le monde se pose en en
europe s'il est ce que la flambée et
durable tout dépend de l'évolution de la
fièvre politique et c'est la fièvre
politique entre l'allemagne la russie et
l'europe ça va demander un peu de temps
en ce qui concerne l'économie il n'y a
pas de risque sur l'activité la
cinquième vague du coc vide serait
beaucoup plus inquiétante mais il ya un
risque d'inflation par la répercussion
des prix de l'énergie sur tous les
autres produits et les services et
l'inflation ça pèse sur le pouvoir
d'achat donc si ça dure on va avoir une
grogne sociale
remonter un peu dans les pays
occidentaux et notamment en france donc
pas de risque politique des risques
sociaux social et politique on verra à
ce moment-là si les mesures de gel des
prix à la consommation qui ont été
prises et qui rentreront en application
suffiront si le chèque inflation est
distribuée complètement mais ça n'est
quand même pas très bon pour emmanuel
macron alors et macro innova voire deux
moyens d'agir là à la rentrée en interne
parce qu'il a la main sur les chèques
énergie mais aussi en externe parce
qu'il sera président de l'europe il aura
donc une certaine influence sur la
définition de la politique européenne à
l'égard de la russie et le président de
l'europe peut essayer de régler des
dissensions avec la russie et avec
l'allemagne tout est lié on peut avoir
une surprise dans la définition de ses
rapports entre la france l'allemagne et
la russie et la surprise ça peut être
une évolution de la politique globale à
l'encontre de la russie on va voir cela
merci beaucoup je marque pour toutes ces
précisions